welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
Michael go Sean and dr. John McNally
will be co-presenting their talk rave
our visualization of intracranial
encephalography dr. bouche Sean is the
professor and vice chair of basic
research in the department of
neurosurgery and neuroscience and the
director of the core for advanced MRI at
Baylor College of Medicine dr. John
menotti
is an assistant professor of
Neurosurgery at the hell at College of
Medicine for complete biography on our
speaker please visit biography tab
located at the top of your screen
I'm dr. Marashi my question you and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
you're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
words we would like to extend our
special thanks to the brain initiative
program directors in particular dr.
James NAB for their efforts in
organizing today's session before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we would
encourage you to participate in
submitting questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen and type your questions
and drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions by email
following the presentation this
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Beauchamp and
dr. McNally
thanks very much for joining us today my
name is Michael Beauchamp and I'm going
to be telling you about the software
package that we're developing known as
rave for our analysis and visualization
of intracranial encephalography the
development team
package is consists of myself and my
colleagues John McNally and Zhang Xiao
Wang and the funding for the development
of rave was provided by the NIH brain
initiative so the outline of the talk
today will consist of two parts the
first part is a PowerPoint presentation
which will take you through some of the
background and development goals of rave
and the main part of the top will
consist of a demo of the software
package itself presented by my colleague
John mcnutty so the first question to
answer is what is rave useful for and
essentially it's useful for analyzing
brain data recorded from electrodes
implanted in the brains of human
participants this technique has a number
of different names intracranial EEG also
II cog when we refer into grids or
strips of electrodes or stereo EEG which
is the tech the name used to when we
insert penetrating or depth electrodes
into the brain and the rave logo
contains both kinds of electrodes and
they are and the II those are strips of
electrodes and a and the V those are
meant to portray depth electrodes and as
you can see in the graph this technique
is growing rapidly in popularity with
many hundreds of new publications every
year devoted to this method because it
has a unique combination of high spatial
and high temporal resolution which is
important for understanding the brain
why we need rave is best understood with
analogy to another new technique fMRI
which became started to become popular
in the mid 1990s at that time there was
no software packages for analyzing fMRI
data so each lab was forced to develop
their own set of idiosyncratic tools
this was a big obstacle to progress
because this was difficult and
scientists had to spend a lot of time
developing software tools which was not
their area of expertise rather than
doing experiments so with the creation
of purpose-built fMRI software like FSL
brain Voyager and especially after which
is developed by one of our collaborators
Bob Cox non-programmers and non
engineers could do experiments and
analyze fMRI data to make discoveries
about the brain and we're at a similar
point in intracranial EEG right now most
labs
using a hodgepodge of software tools
that they've downloaded from the
internet or MATLAB code that they've
written themselves and this presents a
serious obstacle to progress because
grad students or postdocs or PI's have
to spend time writing MATLAB code which
maybe they're not well equipped to do or
develop statistical tasks instead of
analyzing data and making discoveries
about the brain so our goal is to create
a purpose-built software package that's
designed solely for intracranial EEG and
has the flexibility necessary to make
discoveries about the brain and our
development goals for rave our most
important goal is to keep users close to
the data because the brain is so
complicated and there's so much we don't
know about it it's absolutely critical
that you have the ability to examine raw
data and make sure that you're not
misled by artifacts there can be
artifacts in intracranial EEG data like
in any other kind of data and if you are
only looking at the final product of the
analysis which a long analysis pipeline
might spit out you might not realize
that some are along the analysis
pipeline one of the steps had gone awry
and the final map that you're looking at
is absolutely meaningless so the good
thing is that computers are so rapid now
that we can do real-time interactive and
data analysis without leaving it to run
overnight which you might have had to do
20 years ago with fMRI data so you can
easily update your analysis in real-time
and see what happens and this makes it
easy to analyze interest if you have the
right software tool it makes it much
more efficient to analyzed data second
we want to have rigorous statistical
methodology again by analogy with fMRI
there's been periodic paroxysms of
controversy and fMRI for instance in the
early days subjects were treated as
fixed effects when it soon be eventually
became clear that really no subjects
were not all identical they needed to be
treated as random effects and many other
kinds of statistical arguments so the
part of this comes because people are
making arbitrary choices who have not
necessarily had any training statistics
and are just using a tool box or a
MATLAB function so by building a
purpose-built program we can make wise
choices and encourage people to do it
now
see the right way of course we're not
prescriptive but we can say okay the
built-in way that rave analyzes data has
been vetted by statisticians and decided
that it's a rigorous way to analyze data
and the final goal of rave development
is to make sure that it plays well with
others that is to say that it allows you
to work with existing tools that you
might have in MATLAB or C or Python and
integrate it into your existing
processing pipeline so that you don't
have to give up all the tools that you
already know and love so the current
state of rave development is that we
have more than 10 statistical modules
over 30,000 lines of code in the
codebase and it's being used on a daily
basis by many labs at Baylor College of
Medicine and of course we would love for
other users to use it as well and you
can download it for free from github or
from the website that's shown on this
slide and we're working on rave every
day to try to improve it so in the
second part of the talk you're going to
hear my colleague going through some of
the awesome features of rave and we're
going to demonstrate it on some real
intracranial EEG data that we collected
and that was published in a paper in
Elife in 2018 and I'll just briefly
introduce that dataset to you to make it
easier to understand when you see it
analyzed within rave so this is a study
where we presented patients with three
kinds of stimuli these were short video
clips of words so as you can see in the
left part of the screen it could be a
video clip where you could both see the
face of the talker and hear the talker
so for instance the talker would say the
word dr and you would see there in this
case my former student audrey now if you
would see her lips move in the middle
condition the visual only condition you
wouldn't hear any sound you would just
see the face of the talker move and in
the final condition auditory only you
would not see anything except the white
fixation point on screen but you would
hear the word dr so those are the three
main conditions and we went to st.
Luke's Episcopal Hospital where we
worked with eight different patients who
had had electrodes implanted in their
brains for the treatment of medically
intractable epilepsy after they
recovered from the surgery they rest
comfortably in their hospital room
and if they wish they can participate in
our experiments and that involves them
looking at a screen as you can see on
this cartoon here and holding a mouse to
make behavioral responses so in this
experiment they would see 30 to 60
repetitions of each of the words in each
different condition and they would press
a mouse button when they heard a
specific words in this case the word
press so these patients had electrodes
implanted in their brains as you can see
we created a cortical surface model of
the brain each red dot shows one
electrode in the bottom left of the
slide you can see the pictures of the
grids or strips before they were
implanted in the brain each of the grids
or strips has wires that are channelized
out of the patient's head you can see
the wire coming from the top of the
bandage in the middle cartoon and fed
into a Blackrock system where the data
is recorded to a computer hard disk
after we collect the data we can feed it
into Rave and do many different kinds of
analysis just to give you an idea with
the kind of analysis two kinds of
analysis that raw voltage signal the red
trace shows the data from one electrode
over the course of a second or two the
y-axis on that plot is the voltage front
recorded from that electrode and the
little single frames of the movie
represent the onset of a movie so we
could either create up to a voltage
analysis and calculated event-related
potential as sort of classic EEG
analysis as shown in the bottom left or
we could do a time frequency analysis
where we do a spectral decomposition of
that voltage signal and as you can see
the x-axis or time is the same at the
wax now has been transformed into
frequency and you can see there's a big
blotch of red color showing that there's
a large amplitude increase in these high
frequency high frequency broadband
activity from around 40 or 50 Hertz all
the way up to 150 or 200 Hertz when the
movie begins so I want to emphasize that
one of the big challenges of
intracranial EEG data is we have so much
data there's many participants hundreds
of electrodes we're sampling that up to
30 or 40 kilohertz in some cases we have
many trials many conditions so we need
special software tools to analyze this
data and the tool that we're going to
demonstrate to you again is called rave
and I will now pause the presentation
and turn it over to my colleague John
McDonough
all right thank you Mike for introducing
the software package as you can see on
the screen this is the main loading page
for rave raves consists of a set of
modules that allow you to both pre
process visualize and analyze
intracranial EEG data this is orient you
to the screen on the left side is the
modules pane currently we're looking
inside the condition Explorer set of
modules that's a power Explorer module
and there are different modules in rave
as Mike alluded to you can look at
voltage you can look at phase you can
conduct group analyses across subjects
and there's also some metadata that you
can look at but let's jump right into
the power Explorer so the top left shows
the electrode that we're currently
looking at it's electrode 22 will orient
you in a minute to where this electrode
is and you can see just to the right of
the electrodes panel this is a
spectrogram just like you saw in the
last PowerPoint slide
so what rave allows you to do is
interactively surf through spectrograms
very easily so in the middle left pane
I'll scroll down a little bit so you can
see it we can select both the
frequencies of interest the baseline
window this is a period of time when the
subject is doing nothing relative to the
task and then also our analysis window
this is the region when the video is
being presented so that's how we get
this black box that's drawn on top of
the spectrogram one of the interesting
things about Iike to other techniques is
that on each individual trial we can
actually see significant brain activity
and so here in the middle panel we're
plotting this average power inside the
frequency range of interest on each
trial so the y-axis here each row is an
individual trial I've labeled the trials
by what video the person is watching
these particular videos have a blank
screen and they're only hearing the word
that you see so at the top is last then
meant known and then drive and
what you can see in these plots is that
there's a very consistent increase in
what we'll call high gamma power a
little bit after the auditory comes on
for all these plots x zero is the start
of the acoustic sound and it's
interesting that you can see that
there's variation across the stimuli but
by and large there is great similarity
in response to each stimulus as we
continue to scroll down rave shows a
time series plot shows you that during
the baseline period this is controlled
to be zero to be mean zero and then
right after the auditory onset at time
zero the power increases and then after
about a quarter of a second starts to
decrease and this analysis window
defines the time at which we're going to
do our statistical comparisons so the
final plot on the bottom right this
shows you for each individual trial this
is the average power within that red
window so each point here is the trial
response to a particular stimulus and by
default for a single condition we can
just compare that activity to zero to
see if this electrode had a significant
response to these auditory only stimuli
now of course we can go back up to the
top and change the electrode we're
looking at for example what if we look
at an electrode that's in the auditory
cortex or see me as a visual cortex so
here electrode 78 that's in the visual
cortex we can see that there's not
really a strong response at all to the
auditory signal you know very slightly
elevated above zero but compared to the
previous channel there's really not
anything going on however what if we
look at the visual responses to the
visual stimuli so I can go over to the
trial selector and start to add in these
other trial types
click all of these I can apply a label
call these visual
and what you can immediately see in the
is that when we add in a second group of
trials and that rave now shows these
side by side and so although there isn't
a very strong response in to the
auditory stimuli there's a very strong
response to the visual only stimuli so
these are the stimuli where you just see
the person talking but you don't hear
anything and when we go back down and
look at the time series now we see both
time series overlay and then in the
bottom right graph we can see that here
there's a much stronger response to the
visual trials compared to the auditory
only trials and so we could do this for
all the electrodes that we've loaded but
rave also has ability to take this
contrast that we've defined this
auditory versus visual contrast and
apply it to every electrode that has
been loaded on the brain so this takes a
few seconds but I've already pre-loaded
this calculation and so here you can see
really nice the topographic organization
of this contrast so towards the bottom
right in the superior temporal gyrus
there's a lot of red so these are
regions of the brain that respond more
to the auditory stimulus than to the
visual only stimulus as we rotate the
brain and look at the back of the brain
we can see that there's a lot more blue
and so these electrodes are responding
more to the visual stimulus than to the
auditory stimulus now using rave I can
click on these different blue channels
so this blue one here in the middle is
electrode 78 and that allows us to then
scroll up and see okay yes that's the
electrode that we're looking at now
electrode 78 but we can find other
electrodes that we want to inspect so
electrode 22 is the electrode we were
looking at initially but let's look over
at for instance electrode 23
so we can simply type in 23 into the
electrode screen and rave automatically
updates to show you the new calculations
for this new electrode and what's
interesting if we scroll down and look
at the time series we can see that
although the response the auditory only
is much higher than the response
dividual only there does seem to be a
response to visual only trials and so
what you might want to do is what if we
delete the trials for auditory only now
rave will update to only show the visual
only trials and if we look at the
comparison here although the response is
smaller it's still significant so in the
bottom right panel we can see again the
individual trial plots and the mean of
this is 63% so there is a significant
change significant response to visual
stimuli
even though auditory is much stronger
and this accords with what we know about
this region of the posterior superior
temporal gyrus as being multi-sensory
and so it's responding both to auditory
alone and visual alone stimuli and so
you could repeat this process with all
of your different subjects we don't have
time to show you today how rave is
organized but there is a select Data
button that allows you to quickly choose
which subjects that you want to load and
this is organized by projects and so
I'll just show you in the drop down here
based on which project you want to load
we're looking out the congruence data
set but you can see we have lots and
lots of data sets that were you we've
analyzed with rave and even within this
congruence data set we've already
analyzed lots of different subjects so
we are using Ray's on a day to day basis
the last step that you might want to do
in your analysis is to try to look at
some of these comparisons across all of
your subjects so I'll jump over here to
the group analysis module on the far
left and choose the linear mix effects
model so we've loaded up in our mixed
sex model module all of our subjects
from the congruence data set and what
rave allows you to do here in this model
building panel in the middle left is
actually choose how you want to model
your data and so we'll model our data
with the dependent variable being power
look at a fixed effects of condition so
it's going to compare auditory versus
audio-visual it's also going to include
some other trial types I've had in this
experiment here it's showing you in the
formula panel the exact formula that's
being used and so this way if you need
to report in a paper
how are my statistics actually done you
can just you can say this is exactly the
command that was run we choose run
analysis and depending on how much data
you have it may take you know faster or
slower and we can see here that the LME
output panel rave now reports everything
you need to know to compare condition
across all of your subjects and it
appropriately takes into account both
the fact that subjects are random effect
but also that electrodes are nested
within subject and so this is part of
our goal to present more modern
statistical techniques as just the way
things are just the way rave works so
we've shown you today just to reiterate
that in rave we have a modular interface
that allows you to compare conditions
using power voltage phase and then once
you've made those analyses you can
export them to the group level and then
see if your the differences that you see
at the individual electrodes are
consistent across patients thank you
you
thank you gentlemen for that
presentation of this cutting edge worm
as a reminder our speaker will follow up
with any questions about their
presentation by email
coming up next dr. BJ Hasan
he will present human brain science the
intersection of transitional nerve
technology and systems neuroscience with
a heart to seeing you there